speleologo una parola un po difficile da
pronunciare significa semplicemente una
persona che per curiosità per passione
per ricerca scientifica decide di
avventurarsi in quel mondo sotterraneo
che si sviluppa sotto i nostri piedi
all'interno delle montagne è un luogo
che di fatto rappresenta una delle
ultime frontiere esplorative del nostro
pianeta ed è difficile da immaginare
liberamente difficile da definire se
pensate alla geografia una cartina
geografica quella rappresenta soltanto
la superficie del nostro pianeta
mentre il mondo sotterraneo un mondo che
sostanzialmente noi ignoriamo è come se
non ci fosse per questo a me piace
chiamarlo il continente buio ma prima di
portarli a vedere un po di queste
meraviglie di queste terre della notte
vi voglio confessare una cosa quando ero
bambino avrà una paura tremenda del buio
e mi consola il fatto che questa paura è
stata condivisa premente con tantissimi
bambini e se ci pensate
la vita comincia nel grembo materno
proprio nell'oscurità
ed è quello oscurità che ci separa dal
mondo esterno ci difende da ciò che
ancora non conosciamo
da ciò che ancora non c'è stato svelato
e nascere vivere per cominciare
intraprendere un esplorazione e i
bambini sono gli esploratori per
eccellenza perché ogni loro scoperta
porta della conoscenza porta esperienza
ed è un'esplorazione che è prima di
tutto geografica cioè capire il mondo
dove ci troviamo dove viviamo
quello che ci sta intorno poi diventa
cognitiva sensoriale umana e così via
e questa esplorazione e soprattutto
quando sei bambini è dettata da due
principali sentimenti di cui ci ha
lasciato una bellissima descrizione
leonardo da vinci proprio trovandosi
all'imboccatura di una caverna oscura
come questo lo speleologo subito si
destarono in me due cose pauraedesiderio
paura per la minacciosa e buia spelonca
è la paura dell'ignoto la paura di ciò
che non si conosce di qualcosa che
potrebbe essere al di fuori della nostra
portata
desiderio per vedere se là dentro
qualcuna misteriosa cosa il desiderio di
andare oltre fare un passo e andare
oltre l'orizzonte e vedere qualcosa che
non si conosce meravigliarsi per
qualcosa che non abbiamo neanche
immaginato ben presto per tutti noi
crescendo il desiderio di vedere
chiaramente al sopravvento sulla paura e
così anche anche per me
già da ragazzino in questo caso proprio
per un'esplorazione fisica nel senso di
andare a vedere le grotte che c'erano
sui monti lessini proprio qui vicino a
verona una zona carsica dove ci sono
moltissime cavità e una in particolare
sulla subito mi ha colpito molto famosa
che è la spluga della preta su qui sul
corno d'aquilio qui vedete il primo
pozzo di 130 metri ma voragine
profondissima arriva quasi 900 metri di
profondità sotto la superficie della
terra a uno sviluppo attualmente
rilevato conosciuto di circa 8 km
ma questa grotta non è tanto importante
per la sua profondità al suo sviluppo i
meravigliosi pozzi che al suo interno
quanto per la sua storia perché è una
storia che è esemplificativa e ci spiega
il perché gli uomini si avventurano in
questi luoghi così remoti e nascosti del
nostro pianeta
tutto cominciò nel 1925 quando la
sezione universitaria del cai di verona
decise di affrontare questo buco che si
apriva nei prati per sondarne nelle
profondità non avevano nessuna
esperienza di speleologia non sapevano
cosa avrebbero trovato sapevano che era
un buco profondissimo pensate che
avevano così paura che scesero con delle
rivoltelle perché erano pronti per
sparare chissà quali mostri che potevano
incontrare la sotto in realtà non
incontrava nessun mostro particolare ma
incontrano semplicemente altro ignoto
c'è l'abisso continua va in profondità e
loro non ero in grado di continuare
perché i loro mezzi a quei tempi non
erano così così diciamo importanti come
quelli che magari abbiamo adesso
e da lì è cominciato a tutta
un'esplorazione questi ignoto questo
buio che continuava e nelle profondità
attirato moltissime persone un po da
tutto il mondo a cimentarsi in questa
grotta e cercare di portare avanti
sempre limite esplorativo
qui vedete una una immagine della
discesa esca la corda del 1962 quella
che fu la super spedizione alla spluga
della preta organizzata dal gruppo
grotte falchi di verona ma soprattutto
vedete questa la copertina della
domenica del corriere del 1954 che uscì
esattamente una settimana dopo la famosa
copertina della conquista del k2 infatti
finché ardito desio cercava di
conquistare quella sua squadra la cima
della seconda montagna più alta della
terra contemporaneamente ma fuori dai
riflettori per il chiaramente al buio
gli speleologi italiani cercavano di
conquistare l'ha visto più profondo del
mondo
tuttavia questo parallelismo tra
alpinismo filologia non è del tutto
corretto in quanto la montagna è un
oggetto che noi possiamo facilmente
comprendere lo possiamo abbracciare con
lo sguardo anche senza salirvi sopra lo
possiamo vedere con un'immagine
satellitare e soprattutto ogni montagna
un limite ben definito che la vetta
oltre la quale non è possibile andare
c'è solo il cielo
la grotta invece se voi andate sul corno
d'aquilio non vedrete la spluga della
preta vedete l'ingresso della studio
dell'atleta la grotta l'abisso è un
luogo che è veramente difficile da
comprendere immaginare tutto quello che
conosciamo è solo quello che abbiamo
percorso ciò che non è stato esplorato
rimane nell'oblio nell'ignoto quindi
anche il fondo di una grotta come la
struttura pret à il fondo della spluga
che io conosco potrebbe tra qualche anno
non esserlo più perché qualcun altro
potrebbe arrivare guardando
nell'oscurità dove noi non abbiamo visto
individuare un nuovo passaggio che
scende ancora in tutto in profondità
quindi la grotta nella sua limitatezza
l'abisso nella sua limitatezza
dall'interno della nostra del nostro
pianeta ci dimostra come sia in figli in
esplorazione sia infinita non saremo mai
in grado di conoscere tutto quanto
anch'io ho avuto la fortuna nel 2003 di
esplorare di fare una nuova esplorazione
nostro che da atleta e e questo mi ha
chiaramente segnato moltissimo proprio
il fatto di entrare in un luogo che
prima non esisteva di fatto non esisteva
per l'uomo perché non non era alla
portata della conoscenza dell'uomo e
anche quindi il fatto di meravigliarsi o
di rimanere estasiati di fronte a queste
meraviglie della natura e quindi ho
cominciato tutto un percorso insieme col
team di esplorazioni geografiche la
venta di esplorazioni in giro per i
continenti perché il nostro interesse è
anche capire queste grotte come si
sviluppano i vari ambienti dalle foreste
del messico del chapas del sudamerica
delle filippine agli ambienti desertici
qui siamo in uzbekistan botta quasi
quattromila metri
e così via fino ad arrivare all'ultimo
progetto che quello che più mi sta a
cuore questo momento che l'esplorazione
delle grotte dei the pooh i veneziani
questi massicci che si trovano tra
venezuela e brasile nella zona della
gran sabana dell'amazzonia che si
trovano all'interno di montagna
antichissime montagna che hanno un
miliardo e 600 milioni di anni e le
grotte stessi sono le grotte più antiche
che possiamo trovare sul nostro pianeta
e contengono delle forme di vita
soprattutto batteriche sono molto
interessanti per capire l'origine e
l'evoluzione della vita sul nostro
pianeta ma un'altra cosa che ho imparato
molto importante tutte queste
esplorazioni è questa che la realtà
supera sempre è di gran lunga
l'immaginazione che noi possiamo pensare
immaginare fantasticare come vedete in
questa illustrazione di giulio verne nel
che cosa ci potrebbe essere sotto la
superficie della terra ma la realtà
quando andremo a scoprire se supererà
sempre la nostra fantasia infatti chissà
cosa avrebbe detto giulio verne se
avesse visto un secolo e mezzo dopo
questa grotta in messico nella miniera
di naica la curva dei cristalli giganti
di nike a questa scoperta alla nei primi
anni duemila è stata esplorata dalla
venta è una foresta di cristalli che
arrivano fino a 13 metri di lunghezza ed
è una grotta che ci insegna una cosa
anche molto interessante questa grotta
non aveva un accesso sulla superficie
del pianeta è stata intercettata da una
galleria mineraria
quindi è una grotta una cavità che è più
legata alle profondità della terra che
non ha la superficie e tutto quello che
conosciamo del mondo sotterraneo
sostanzialmente sono quelle cavità
quelle grotte che hanno un accesso alla
superficie sono quelle dove noi possiamo
entrare ma tutte quelle che invece non
hanno nessun accesso alla superficie
quelle conosceremo mai se non per caso
come in questa situazione e quindi
chissà quante altre grotte come quella
di cristalli o con chissà quale
meraviglie esistono che noi non avremmo
mai la possibilità di conoscere perché
non esiste nessun metodo scientifico
geofisico che riesca veramente ad andare
a investigare queste cavità sotto
sotterraneo un'altra cosa molto
importante che ho imparato in questi
anni di esplorazioni è che non serve
andare lontano per fare esplorazione non
è necessario attraversare gli oceani
andare in altri continenti luoghi remoti
l'idea dell'esploratore che abbiamo
soprattutto in questi anni 2000 del
ventesimo secolo diciamo è quella che
l'esploratore deve andare lontano
pensiamo un esploratore in antartide nei
deserti dell'asia nei posti più remoti
nou dove c'è ancora magari l'uomo ancora
non ha intaccato dalla natura
in realtà non è così si può anche
esplorare alle porte di casa ed è quello
che fanno gli speleologi
anche qui in italia e adesso vi racconto
un paio di storie per dimostrarvi
proprio ambientate qui in veneto in
particolare nelle dolomiti questo che
vedete è lo spallone est del monte pelmo
sopra a san vito di cadore e vedete
questi buchi sulla parete che si
vedevano anche dal paese pensate non
erano mai stati raggiunti non ci sono
vie alpinistiche che passano li vicino e
sarà questa curiosità soprattutto della
gente del paese anche per capire che
cosa fossero come la venta siamo stati
invitati da uno scultore mauro lampo li
voto a tentare di scendere la parete che
alte circa mille metri e raggiungere
queste grotte in parete quindi un luogo
che è veramente alla portata c'è
calandoci noi sentivamo le campane dei
paesi sotto della valle del boia ma che
di fatto era estremamente lontano mai
raggiunto da nessuno e le grotte
come vedete non sono delle grotte enormi
non sono
note lunghe chilometri ma non è solo una
questione di un'esplorazione diciamo
geografica di metri ma anche di capire
cosa c'è al loro interno in questo caso
ci sono dei sedimenti antichissimi che
potrebbero dare delle informazioni
sull'evoluzione geografica delle
dolomiti quindi è un'esplorazione che
anche scoperta e poi si trasforma
ricerca scientifica ormai l'esploratore
non è più nessuno senza lo scienziato e
questo coinvolge non solo l'ambiente
sotterraneo ma anche l'ambiente che ci
sta intorno pensate che qui sopra
proprio mettendo le corde per effettuare
questa calata ci siamo accorti che su
una lastra di roccia
c'erano delle piccole depressioni
allineate le abbiamo fotografate e
subito abbiamo avuto l'intenzione che
potessero essere delle impronte di
dinosauro e sono attualmente in studio
da parte dell'università di padova sono
tra i più alte impronte di dinosauro mai
scoperte nelle alpi e qui le vedete con
una scultura di mauro lampo che ha
voluto omaggiarli le impronte delle loro
miti un'altra storia interessante più
recente e qui vedete un elicottero che
sta partendo per allestire un campo
sulpis conturines nel parco naturale di
senes fosse braies nell'ottobre del 2015
abbiamo organizzato questa spedizione
tra in collaborazione fra vari gruppi i
veneti e la venta per risolvere un
mistero che è cominciato nel 1994 vedete
questo laghetto alpino a quasi 3.000
metri di quota nel 94 in una notte si
svuotò improvvisamente sostanzialmente
il laghetto era una depressione che
poggiava su un ghiacciaio sotterraneo
che si è presenta sciolto in parte per i
cambiamenti magari ultimati c attuali e
ha risucchiato tutta l'acqua lasciando
aperto un pertugio nel ghiaccio che
scendeva verso chissà quali profondità è
stata una situazione molto difficile
condotta inizialmente dal club slow
logico prodotto di vicenza attraverso un
dedalo di condotti ghiacciati che
possono essere affrontati solo in
periodi determinati periodi dell'anno in
quanto sullo scioglimento
della fusione del ghiaccio alimento dei
torrenti interni che altrimenti non
permettono l'esplorazione nel 2010 siamo
arrivati a superare il tappo di ghiaccio
di circa 100 metri di spessore ed
entrare in una sala gigantesca che
attualmente la sala sotterranea più
grande mai scoperta nelle dolomiti e
quest'anno nel 2015 siamo tornati per
riuscire a portare fuori qualche
informazione in più di questo di questa
cattedrale sotterranea di capirne
veramente le dimensioni e per fare
questo abbiamo utilizzato un laser
scanner una strumentazione molto
avanzata che permette sostanzialmente di
ottenere un modello tridimensionale
dell'ambiente qui ci vedete siamo appesi
a 110 metri di altezza con questo
strumento è stata anche una spedizione
molto rocambolesca il tecnico dell'aget
scanner era abbastanza spaventato ma
alla fine ne è uscito molto contento
quello che vedete adesso è un po quello
il risultato
vedete noi scalcinati sulla destra
la piattaforma e pensate che questa
scansione hanno ammesso di capire che
questa capitale a sottrarre altri 110
metri volume di mezzo gli alimenti poco
serio nella vendita di soffietti e
questa scansione permetterà che il
titolo di capire come sta attualmente
ghiaccio di interrogazioni maniche
chiaramente mi piacciono mi piace
all'inter con ha registrato cambiamenti
climatici globali di migliaia di anni fa
e attualmente fa registrando quelli
attuali e quindi avere un confronto per
il mitico sarà estremamente importante
troppo spesso pensiamo che non ci sia
più niente da esplorare
abbiamo relegato l'idea dell'ignoto
pianeti lontani a galassie all'universo
ma questo succede soltanto perché
abbiamo perso vivendo qua sulla nostra
terra da adulti abbiamo perso quella
sensibilità alla paura il desiderio
verso l'ignoto che avevamo da bambini è
sufficiente cambiare la nostra visione
non dare mai nulla per scontato e ci
accorgeremo che c'è ancora tantissimo da
scoprire da esplorare anche qui sulla
nostra terra e non serve andare lontano
non serve attraversare gli oceani per
potersi meravigliare per poter scoprire
qualcosa di nuovo le esplorazioni sono
anche qui alle porte di casa è
sufficiente mettersi questi occhi da
bambini guardare la terra
in questo modo dell'esploratore e forse
avremmo anche meravigliandoci avremo più
riguardo verso il nostro pianeta terra
e potremmo continuare a meravigliarci
della natura conservandole proteggendola
grazie